aujourd'hui je sais c'est le jour du
mien culpa donc parfois je digère pas ce
qu'on me le dit avec moi on arrête de
type t'es pas gentil même ma maman un
peu me dire ça et tu fait de tes pas
gentil avec gérard votre mère vous
disais que vous n'étiez pas gentil avec
gérard est avec moi exactement
deux tiers des salariés sont confrontés
à cette conflictuelle it et au travail
en fait il n'y a que 5 % 5 % des
salariés interrogés qui disent ressentir
un très fort sentiment de sécurité
psychologique dans leur entreprise ça
fait pas beaucoup mais nous il faut que
tu nous tiens
vous avez remarqué oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe vous êtes vous écoutez votre mère
c'est
pour le prochain quinquennat
clp le truc on devrait écouter sa maman
ce buzz williams il concerne ceux que
l'on surnomme les anti vaccins mais qui
sont réfractaires à la vaccination
voici les commentaires de l'un d'entre
eux qui est pompier en guadeloupe gens
debout nous sommes là parce que sinon si
on accepte ça aujourd'hui c'est
apprendre le matin ce sera notre liberté
c'est pour ça peut être un doigt coupé
un bon un bras un doigt ce sera peut
être que la sodomie aussi par ben voyons
c'est pareil je disais quelques assauts
demi on a plus de recul peut-être accès
en avance si on recule le doigt je
refuse oui je sais pas si c'était
vacciner chez un proctologue ailleurs
dans tous les faux quand
ça ne va pas lui plaire
passons à libération qui pose la
question se pose tout ce qui
remplacerait emmanuel bacon s'il devait
lui aussi subir
excusez moi vous y pensez jamais ça
c'est du journalisme d'investigation en
profondeur comme j'ai envie de dire je
trouve que les non vaccinés nous gonfle
et je suis pour je le redis ici je sais
que ça les choque je m'en fiche je suis
pour leur faire payer leurs frais
d'hôpitaux s'ils doivent être
hospitalisées à cause du peu vite
elle va faire du bruit
et en allemagne voilà la déclaration
choc du ministre de la santé aujourd'hui
[Musique]
d'ici à la fin de cet hiver
après tout le monde en allemagne sera
actionné guérit bien décédé
c'est un truc de dingue c'est plein ou
quoi je sais pas moi je
yade et je comprends pas tout il ya des
fois j'ai l'impression de vivre sur une
autre planète et nous ne savions pas
mais joe baydan possède un pouvoir
magique il parle le langage d'inde oui
il a fait dans d'élever deux ailes lui
répondent
[Musique]
il est vraiment très fort l'homme qui
murmurait à l'oreille des dindes et donc
au bout de combien de temps tu te dis
c'était fini aubade et la prise en main
eric tu veux ta prison
la prise en main parlons-en ça s'est
fait dès que vanessa est parti le
lendemain ben voilà ça y est
le lendemain c'est que c'est toujours la
gueule à faire marie ont
failli y aller bah oui fallait y aller
en faire le point
oui ma chère vous avez un souci avec
mais je vais pas mâché viella que de la
crevette que tu aimes pas la queue
pardon
en tout cas pas les queues de crevettes
n'ont as tu sais déjà qui t'accompagne
non je sais pas
tirage au sort à la fin d'émission il
m'a regardé comme dépanner sur ce coup
d'arrêt
moi je moi je peux le prendre si tu sais
pas avec qui elles n'ont
jamais
convoqué allez
bon non par la presse voilà c'est une
honte en 2d est gênante mais fait du
rentre dedans comme ça moi qui ville
dans la séduction douche oui
c'est dur belle route du bout du monde
établi basé du baril brut pourquoi vous
trouvez que l'atb aux yeux mais c'est ce
que je me disais tout à l'heure mais non
c'était ma vient interviewer avant
aujourd'hui je me suis mis thomas il
était si incroyable
monsieur vert
comme çà il prend confiance nécessaire
gilles même si les votes se font avant
mais c'est pas un brunch avec un filtre
restera moche north est annoncée
je suis le même
chaque fois ces projets
mais
c'est julien courbet l'appareil vous
venez de raccrocher mais certainement
par erreur nous soutenons toujours pas
elle a raccroché de nouveau
marie-jeanne je t'aime
caméra je voudrais pas être
rue mais
[Musique]
boris johnson s'exprimait à l'occasion
de la
messe annuelle de l'organisation
patronale britannique et le lundi c'est
compliqué pour tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
payer mais
bon
et bien évidemment j'ai sages vont
possiblement ça c'est un millefeuille
chez un peu distrait ce que françois
perret qu'elle avait que stéphane danny
gale s'est passé comment
vous en avez dans la moustache monarchie
qui on regarde le roi manger
[Rires]
dit que vous êtes lady gaga
alors on n'y croyait pas vraiment mais
incroyable ça fonctionne elle est venue
en
[Musique]
hockey comment
oui
monica marche à nouveau et c'est grâce à
quatre prothèse en titane et à la
générosité des internautes il y a un an
le sort de cette chaîne russe et
rentrent blessées probablement mutilés
avaient été mus de nombreuses personnes
et près de 5000 euros avaient été
récoltés pour lui venir en aide
aujourd'hui l'animal se remet bien de
l'opération et entame sa rééducation sur
les réseaux sociaux on voit chaque jour
monique a progressé à grands pas
[Musique]